you know the but that role it's called
foot you've never had one no no the
green package know what you're talking
about favorite snacks today I'm here
with a couple of my Korean American
friends and we're gonna be talking about
how he grew up in America as Korean
immigrants or international students I
was born in Korea Seoul I moved to
Diamond Bar TV went to college in Boston
and then moved back to that I was born
in Korea so I moved out to America in
2002 and then I came to California ever
since then I just I just stayed here I
came here in 2002 and my family or my
first place in United States was Waikiki
after Hawaii
I got LA OC and a fuller term now I'm
living next to the La Crescenta but
basically California but yeah yeah I was
born in Korea 2002 our family Ward
decided to move to New Zealand first
2006 I'm look to the Sin City Las Vegas
and then I moved to Idaho for Boise
State University then you've been living
here for almost a year I don't think
I've ever talked about looking Jeju I
said I just tell you another handy given
a total equals no means Wieck watch
worker and the kuvakin gateways on this
agency boo boo boo me Rhonda many some
mention of where Ted Cinco much you know
that could be on the cage or a single
array a high-energy cosmic boy oh na na
kotoba not happy Kolkata we can focus on
analyzing here and there thanks to
social media I see Tom I know yeah yeah
another easy she woulda details no I
wouldn't only child right
it's a Dalek Singh would really like a
brother my sister she would a arm up
going to a box similar to concoct oh go
wrong every holding he knows all too
many refills just wanna come out
I'm Tony violet oh no no no where'd you
go good for not really
come on Dutchman not all new one in
there Croatia the American Civil War who
are God they are young young my clothes
like group of friends we do speak
English but it's like back and forth
Korean engine yeah just like we would
say one sentence in English and we will
say the next set this interior most of
my girlfriends are English speaking
friends but almost all female friends
are Korean speakers which is interesting
my friends like I'm more than like 70%
they use Korea so I mean they mix use
like like right once in this Korean once
the English and joori all my friends are
English in me but I think ever since I
moved into California it's more both
cultures of Korean and America you guys
all do speak Korean in your households
right the uncle Mohammed said Martha
initiative she bizarre situation a lot
of money matter washing money to come
see what about mutton
[Music]
[Laughter]
I listen to God music hey pops I like to
push and if you said the game I think I
was more of a like an arm be partying
like you can't go I took a boom boom
that's alright so I picked up a lot of
slang so a lot of kids make fun of me
you have to learn English first and day
and learn slang so you just draw because
a lot of rap songs grandma doesn't make
sure you know what I mean you got it
right TV shows Fran special bel-air I
don't watch any much my age was 18 right
I had to make some cash that moment so
like I got a job coffee place like a
Starbucks in the mall yeah I need to get
orders from customers right but my
English was really really short just one
lady came up and they're like no a jumbo
unless no you know they must help to
Allah I mean food especially work even
just but really hard yeah many nice that
cried in elementary school when I first
moved I wanted to get a get a get a
Gatorade
Gatorade but that could pronounce it
like colors I just said I was like it
right hi can I get the get today's the
lady who was working at the cafeteria
she wasn't really fluent in English you
know what she couldn't get us I could
buy it I remember just going to drink
like fountain water sadness I think in
both language actually I can't
understand but I don't think a lot of
you errs who understand what there's no
way
Korean or I don't think I think that was
here's a good one do you count
Englishman green well no English English
English Italian Korean oh really yes
it's a lot faster and I drew his head
method instead of one - oh really you
didn't create it whenever I jot down
numbers always thinking green always
positive and see speak I can understand
both languages in my mom right now I'm
thinking English okay
where I grew up people used to say the
Asians are minorities here but I've
never really felt that way from middle
school to high school because about 80%
were Asians oh yeah I was never really
picked on up until I went to Boston yeah
and then I was like the only Asian out
of 400 kids I was like okay this is a
little weird for me in middle school in
New Jersey a lot of kids call me Bob of
course Bob Spence were fresh off of the
boat it's a feeling mean that I just had
to go through every time I go to school
it's an insult you know like nobody
wants to be called Bob's you know right
now it's okay like I'm all grown all we
go we could take as a joke but when
you're like 12 or 13 traumatic what I
clearly remember is there was this
Korean guy in middle school he spoke to
zero Korean but he made an effort to
speak Korean so that he could help me
throughout my school age he saw other
kids making fun of me you know you're
supposed to protect me but he like
started making fun of me with them yeah
he's like joining Bam to make fun of me
so like that like I hope this doesn't
happen anymore I think when I was in
high school people call me like High
Definition was a high because the Y
screen because of something like I just
hope by watching this like they will
learn not to say in those kind of manner
very shoes inside oh yeah you guys
realize how dirty your shoes are you go
everywhere wearing shoes so you have all
that germs and especially like carpets
yeah yeah it collects more time yeah
carpet flooring is actually also my
other culture Shawn I've never I'm
nervous about the flooring in Korea
Korean school your class stays and then
you teacher it and then you have to move
yeah yeah the students move yeah so the
American school you have to make more
friends in Korea you're stuck with them
to entire year was a good culture shock
I was like oh this is cool for me some
the paid tips after you eat yes in Korea
there's no tip culture you know Cheetos
oh my god hot cheetos a first hand hot
cheetos around the corners of course you
have a language barrier you know English
isn't your first language I'm a very
outgoing person as you'll see but like
when I first moved here I got more
introverted because I didn't know the
language I don't know the culture so I
was a scared to talk to people you just
have to break out of that if you can't
speak English it's not stress for you
it's just for the person who you're
talking to
he doesn't understand he's gonna get
stressed but like you just have to speak
your mind chatter less than your order
bones you're telling again tomorrow
marching on watch here not you're
getting older I need some puns get me my
shuttle
do what I got a condo at the college I'm
dealing a hindrance remote romana Iran
TV show Otunga covenant oho create a big
apology whoo vodka caffeine what
[Music]